Jerome Bruna's theory of development is
based on the assumption that we learn
best when we go from concrete to
abstract in a three-step process. First
comes hands-on action, then learning with
images, and finally students transform
what they've learned into language.
throughout the experience we constantly
revisit previously learned topics while
teachers provide carefully structured
guidance along the way. And it seems to
work.. In the 1980's the Singaporean
government decided to stop importing
foreign textbooks and instead build the
world's best maths curriculum from
scratch.
Since that time Singaporeans study fewer
concepts with greater detail following
Bruner's guideline. Before we learn how
well this worked out let's go through
each step of the theory with an example:
First, we learn through en-active
representation. This happens in hands-on
experiences ideally with real-world
applications: to divide 4 by 2, students learn to cut a cake into 4
slices so each can eat one now and bring
one home later.
Step two is iconic representation: we now
link our memories of the experience to
iconic pictures. Students are asked to
draw a cake that was cut into four
pieces.
Last comes symbolic representation. We
now use the images we internalized
earlier and turn them into abstract
language such as mathematical symbols.
Using a little bit of retrospection we
can easily solve the problem.
This last phase is also called language
based because we are really just
learning the right words and symbols to
express our thoughts. The actual maths
knowledge was acquired much earlier
through hands-on experiences. Bruner
therefore advocated for the use of a
spiral curriculum with continuous
repetition of the same fundamental ideas.
The curriculum is comprised of three
characteristics: students revisit the
same topic at regular intervals, the
complexity of the topic increases with
each revisit, the new learning has a
relationship with previous learning.
Teachers also use scaffolding, a term
coined by Bruner. Teachers do this by
structuring activities based on students
existing knowledge and in a way that
helps them to reach the desired learning
outcome. The teacher first demonstrates
the process as the student watches then
the teacher lets the students have a go,
steps back and offers support and
feedback when needed. Today, by the way,
Singapore's fourth and eighth graders
are the world's best in both mathematics
and science and Singapore's maths
curriculum is copied by educators from
around the world. Jerome Bruner was born
blind in New York City in 1915. At the age of
two modern medicine restored his vision.
Later he returned the favor by becoming
a pioneer in cognitive development.
He believed that any subject can be
taught in an intellectually honest form,
to any child, at any stage of development.
What do you think about Bruna's theory
and his suggestion for better learning?
Is this how you learn in your studies? If
not, what is one subject that you think
could be made more understandable by
following his ideas?
if you like this video and the way we
explain the subject subscribe to our
channel we try to explain complex
subjects and simple language and
cartoons to support students all around
the world in their learning if you want
to support us you can go to WWII and
calm sprouts and donate just $1 from